[Music]
the winter season of anime is almost
done so it's time to look ahead it's
probably going to help us in coping with
the fact that demon slayer is done for
now and once the season's over attack on
titan will be as well but the fact still
remains that in a few more weeks winter
will give way to spring and i think it's
appropriate that i get you hyped up for
the stuff we've got coming next season
so it's time once more for vinitube to
put the spotlight on the new anime that
we'll be getting but hey before we start
i'm feeling a little hungry well it's a
good thing we've got today's video
sponsors tokyo treat and sakurako to
deal with that tokyo tree and sakurako
are subscription-based snack boxes that
give you the authentic japanese
experience right in the comfort of your
own home for an affordable subscription
price you get a snack box featuring the
best of japanese sweets culture
delivered to your doorstep every month
tokyo treat gives you a taste of modern
japan by going down this route you'll
get a box that features 20 of the latest
suites that epitomize the concept of
cool japan on the other hand if you
prefer the more traditional side of
japan you can consider sakurako the
circle rocco box goes beyond just sweets
and comes with its own set of artisan
snacks we're talking japanese tea and
even tableware that you can use once
you're through with the box and yeah you
guessed it this month's theme is sakura
so expect many sakura flavoured snacks
so why not be like me and subscribe to
both of them you know enjoy the best of
both sides of japan let me give you a
hand check out the link in the
description box and use code vinnie to
get five dollars off your first box i
guarantee you won't regret spending a
cent on this super good deal
opening our list is skeleton night in
another world
now that's a title that doesn't leave
much to guessing it's exactly what it
says in the title and it's next in line
of the video game it's the kind that
we've been getting for years now gamer
falls asleep wakes up as a skeleton
tonight much to his dismay taken on the
name ark he then meets an elven warrior
who sets him off on his adventure
overpowered character in an isakai
that's taking on a skeletal appearance
doesn't that remind you of overlord i
mean it sure does for me but what i
appreciate with skeleton knight is the
rather lighthearted star it's quite
comedic and i can't get enough of ark's
antics as he takes the knight part of
his name quite literally it's a fine
read as source material nothing too
groundbreaking but something that will
be fun to watch especially if you enjoy
overpowered characters in isakai ninth
in line is love after world domination
[Music]
tell me if you've heard this before two
members of battling forces always find
themselves at each other's throats
however once the cameras stop rolling
and their public life fades the two
pursue their forbidden love our unlucky
heroes this time are fudo of the gelato
5 and desumi of the villainous
organization gekko being on opposite
sides of two factions is difficult
enough but imagine upping the ante with
their roles as heroes and villains their
schedules and assignments only serve to
add more problems in their road to love
but the two are determined to make this
relationship work and not even the most
diabolical plans of world domination
will stop them it's a setup we've seen
quite a lot already but love after world
domination looks to add to the library
of these romeo and juliet-esque stories
with its focus on tokusatsu power
rangers parodies it's quite a funny take
on a story beat that we've grown to be
familiar with and it could be an easy
watch for you to enjoy this season
[Music]
is a lot of things small cute and
adorable all serve well to describe her
however she's also a ball of surprises
completely ignoring the concept of
personal space and being filled with
antics that are bound to drive anyone
mad thankfully super imaginative rado is
perfectly equipped to handle any storm
ahanen whips up this soon leads to a
misunderstanding that sets forth one of
the most unusual friendships between two
peculiar personalities thus begins a
hilarious rom-com where the two dimwits
and the very diverse cast around them
show off some of the craziness that you
wouldn't expect to see out of the
seemingly mundane situations therefore
making it a perfect watch if you're
looking to unwind with some school
wackiness
in seventh place we have a couple of
cuckoos
[Music]
nagi always seem like he doesn't belong
with the rest of the hyper-energetic
umino household well it shouldn't
surprise anyone that this introverted
young man really isn't a member of the
family he's been switched at birth with
another baby as crazy as that sounds
what's even crazier is that nagi has
been arranged to marry social media star
erica armano that's a tad bit
unfortunate for nagi however because he
has his sights set on another girl his
intelligent classmate hiro segalva looks
like our protagonist has found himself
caught in yet another world wind of love
and it's going to take a miracle and all
sorts of hijinks to navigate his way out
of this now i haven't read too much of
the material but it seems to be going
with the same feel as nisakoi and rent a
girlfriend did probably something to
look out for if you enjoyed those shows
[Music]
our sixth most anticipated new anime is
aowashi
here comes the sports show of the season
i've briefly talked about aawashi before
and i think it rightfully finds its
place as one of the most anticipated new
anime this spring like many aspiring
athletes ashita awai dreams big
unfortunately his dreams of getting into
a high school with a good club never
came into fruition due to an incident
that's his fault however the game's
never over until it's over and his talon
catches the eye of some talent scouts
who give him a second chance as during
the typical high school tournament
setting awashi takes the sports genre
further with a focus on actual ball
clubs and a greater emphasis on realism
not only does it give you a glimpse of
the football club system in japan it
also provides some good character growth
to accompany it if you feel that the
typical sport anime is way too
shonen-esque this could be the
alternative you're waiting for
now
fifth on the list is tomodachi game
do you trust your friends with your
lives that's the question posed to us by
the appropriately titled tomodachi game
when yuichi and his friends find
themselves kidnapped by a manabukin
they're forced to play what the mascot
calls friendship games games that will
test their bonds and trust with each
other or to settle a large debt and
snuff out a traitor it's here that they
soon find out that perhaps their
friendship isn't as strong after all and
things look even shakier after a series
of betrayals further proving the adage
to keep your friends close but your
enemies closer it's time for the big
brain pseudo psychological show of the
season domination game starts off slow
but it does pick up quickly holding me
in constant anticipation of what's gonna
happen next i really appreciated the
high stakes mysteries and the characters
in manga form so here's to hoping that
everything translates well in anime
format too
[Music]
at number four is summertime render
[Music]
stood out for some time loot thrillers
summertime render is here for you
shinfei didn't expect much in his return
to his hometown of wakayama he made it
back to attend a funeral of a childhood
friend but some things about ushio's
death seem a miss the forces of darkness
are at work and creeping shadows
threaten the lives of those he holds
dear it's a family reunion gone to hell
armed with the uncanny ability of
turning back time upon death it's up to
him to stop the encroaching darkness and
lead everyone to the greatest happy
ending if you're up for something like
erased or re-zero this is a show you
ought to be on the lookout for i think
summertime render improved on some
aspects of those such as adding even
greater stakes to the mix and upping the
whole mystery aspect i'm calling this to
be a sleeper hit for the season and i
wasn't surprised about the fact that
many people are looking forward to it
finds itself as the third most
anticipated anime this spring season
today
[Music]
at first glance you think that shikimori
and izumi are your typical lovey-dovey
couple they walk home from school they
flirt they tease each other a perfect
couple if you will however izumi is the
type of guy who finds himself in a bind
often and that's when the other
shikimori comes out going from cute to
cool in an instant shikimori knows what
she wants and she knows damn well how to
get it i'm not gonna stand there and
pretend that this show is anything like
the next big breakthrough in the world
of rom-com what i do love about this
show however is how it shows off some
self-awareness and subverts from some
expectations i'm positive we all see
those like yandere vibes already but the
show does a great job playing the
balance between those tropes and the
more wholesome side of teen romance it's
a fun series that goes beyond what you'd
expect from fluffy high school romance
shikimori is not just a cutie indeed
[Music]
the second most anticipated anime is not
a series but a movie
[Music]
it's finally here the anime movie
spectacular that combines some of the
greatest in the industry is here to take
the world by storm bubble takes us to a
tokyo that looks nothing like the
bustling metropolis that we know bubbles
have descended breaking apart the laws
of gravity and turning tokyo into a hot
spot for the coolest sport in town
parkour team battles that have
participants leap from building to
building hotshot parkour prodigy hikibi
then takes one risk too many and finds
himself plummeting down into the sea
where he meets the mysterious ulta a
chance meeting or a union crossed by
fate whatever it is it's this encounter
that opens them up to the truth of the
world name recognition can only take you
so far but from what i've seen in the
trailers bubble looks to be an amazing
title that could be a contender for
original anime movie of the year the
plot synopsis does have potential for
some mystery and romance and i'm really
liking how beautiful everything looks
something you want to keep your eyes out
for
our most anticipated new anime this
spring is spy family
[Music]
spy family has been building steam for
quite some time now the manga has become
so popular that now's the time to strike
with one of the biggest hits we'll see
this year spy family in a nutshell is
about a secret agent forming a pretend
family for the sake of his mission turns
out that his pretend family is made up
of an undercover assassin and a child
with psychic powers what makes spy
family so good to catapulter into the
number one spot on this list the concept
of a fake family going undercover for
their own purposes may not seem as novel
but spy family is a show that nails it
perfectly i just adore the dynamic
between the main characters and it's
truly a joy to watch the contrast and
balance between them dealing with their
assignments and the everyday challenges
of family life it's quite ridiculous but
in a good way and it's a complete joy to
read on a semi-related note i'm feeling
some garguja vibes here despite the
premises almost having nothing in common
do you
mean
have you hopped onto the spy family hype
train tell me and more in the comments
section below comments are good for
views and the algorithm you know you can
also drop by the channel's many many
social media avenues we have a discord
for giveaways an instagram and a patreon
all accessible via the description box
come by and have some fun don't forget
to check out our sponsors of this video
monthly japanese snack subscription
boxes tokyo treat and sakuraku links are
in the description that's going to do it
for this video however i thank you for
watching and i hope that you'll go check
out the channel for the other videos
that may be to your liking i'd love to
see you on the next video but till then
this is vinnie tube signing off